in this video you're going to learn how
to write the domain and the range of a
function in interval notation when
you're given a graph we're going to go
through five examples together and I'm
going to show you how this works see if
you can pause the video on some of the
problems and try them on your own for
practice so the first thing we want to
talk about is what exactly is the domain
and the range
well the domain is what are the possible
X values and the range are what are the
possible y values and so let's take a
look at this first example and I'll show
you kind of how I think about it when I
look at the Domain what I do is I I take
like a line or like a pencil and I kind
of scan from left to right I call this
the horizontal direction or the X
Direction and I scan from left to right
and I see like okay here it's crossing
the graph it's crossing the graph
crossing the graph crossing the graph
and it looks like this graph is
basically going to the left and the
right forever and ever so what that
tells me is that the X's can be
anything all real numbers and so when we
write that we would say the domain is
from negative Infinity
to positive Infinity
and then the range those are like what
the Y values can be so here what I do is
I take a horizontal line and I scan from
low to high like that so I'm scanning
from low to high and you can see this
graphs going down forever and ever but
the highest it goes is right here at a y
value of zero so the range is going to
be from negative Infinity to zero
and it includes zero see it touches
right here at the x-axis so we're going
to use a square bracket because it
includes zero now Infinity can never
reach infinity that's always going to be
like an open with the parenthesis okay
let's look at example number two now
what do you think the domain and the
range are for this one well again when I
think of domain I think what can X be
well when I scan across see it's
crossing the graph
and there's a hole hole here as well so
there's basically a gap here at negative
3. let's write that down
and then you can see it's crossing the
graph
and it keeps going to the right forever
and ever so essentially the domain is
all real numbers except for negative
three that's what the possible X values
are so if I was going to write this
I would just go from left to right so
that's negative Infinity to negative 3
not including negative 3 so we use the
parentheses and then it picks up a
negative 3 not including negative 3 all
the way to positive Infinity now if I
was going to do the range these are the
Y values so I take a horizontal line
like my forearm here and I go from low
to high and it looks like because these
are horizontal lines the Y values can
only be here at negative two and then it
jumps to positive two and it's really
just those two numbers
so instead of writing an interval I
would just use this set bracket notation
I would say negative 2 and positive 2
and just draw those curlicue set
brackets okay so those are the only y
values
what do you think for number three
domain and range for this one
well the domain again what can X be
scanning from left to right looks like
from 1
to five so and it includes one and it
includes five so I would say domain is
one to five using the square brackets
because it includes those values and
then the range what can the Y values be
see low to high see I'm going in the y
direction which is like the vertical
Direction the lowest it can be is
negative two it includes all these
values here up to positive two so I
would say range is negative 2 to
positive 2 inclusive
okay and then what do you think for four
and five maybe pause the video and try
these two for practice
so for number four what can the domain
be what can the X values be
now sometimes people get a little bit
confused by this one because you see how
this is like a parabola it's kind of
like a U-shaped graph so many students
will say well Mario how do you know this
graph doesn't eventually like become
like a vertical line like it's curving
it's getting like steeper and steeper in
a sense
how come how do you know it doesn't just
go vertical well with these it's going
to gradually
go to the left and the right forever and
ever so in this case the domain is going
to be all real numbers or we could say
negative Infinity to positive Infinity
whereas the range going from low to high
okay looking at our y values our
vertical Direction This goes down to
negative infinity and it goes all the
way up to this negative one so here
we'll say the range is negative Infinity
to negative one we're using the square
bracket at negative one because it
includes negative one Infinity remember
is always open you can't really reach
infinity
and then for number five what do you
think for this one what'd you get for
the domain and the range
well for this one again for domain I
think about what can X values be it's
going to be from negative Infinity all
the way to negative one
so let's write that down negative
Infinity to negative 1 including
negative one see how it touches negative
one it's not an open circle that's
closed and then the range what can the Y
values be we can go from low
to high we're thinking the vertical
Direction and this is going down down
down forever so negative Infinity this
is going up up forever and it hits all
those y values in between so it's all
real numbers or you can say negative
Infinity to positive Infinity now the
next thing you're going to want to learn
is how to find the domain when you're
given not the graph but the equation and
I'll put a video for that right there so
follow me over to that video and we'll
talk about how to find the domain given
an equation I'll see you there